what an opportunity I was being asked to
watch the ball the angolan ball game
from the outset how we got into it what
we they're all the rationalization and
justification as well as the
decision-making processes I was to watch
this game not from the 50-yard line but
from from the field itself a player
coach I mean go insane go low and get in
the action where the where the people
are groveling in the dust and losing
their lives as well as the high policy
planning sessions in Washington and I
was delighted to have the opportunity to
sacrifice a year of my life to see just
how the US government does this sort of
thing the see I went into Angola in July
of 1975 we started out with six million
dollars and eventually the total budget
was 31 million dollars the first effort
was arms that were sent from America to
Kinshasa in US Air Force c-141 plane
then from Kinshasa we hold the arms
entangle and smaller the total was about
1,500 tons of arms 30,000 rifles and
small rockets and mortars our funds and
arms were going to two of the three
angola factions one of them hit it up by
Holden Roberto who had had a
relationship with us for about 15 years
and to Sabine Dee who had not been well
known by the CIA he had the sole virtue
of being in opposition to the MPLA and
we were determined to oppose president
Mobutu as a year wanted this program we
bribed we gave us two million $750,000
CIA officers went in as advisors and
trainers they were called intelligence
gatherers but in fact they were
preparing our allies for combat well
Diego fujita-san followed our for India
decision I fled to San Salvador on
January 16th already with a Ilan what
did the enemy do in son solve it
Oh nuki kill VI e you mean what I saw
how long he owns I'm a con the Americans
were there
I'm a canteen how do you know they were
Americans she succumbed service
Americans okay quantity arrow lob when
the villager saw them with their own
eyes
they saw they were Americans medium
worship under the air were 20mm empty
americano for sale
these Americans what did they look like
were they white with a black they
described them now I welcome all
quarters they were your color
comrade a while I caught it no Madame
bread they were not black they had
chestnut eyes you know white there were
not enough CI advisors to make a great
deal of difference however and we hired
European listeners and we tried to hire
white Angolan refugees to go back and
his mercenaries fighting on our side the
CIA collaborated with the South Africans
and it was not officially ordered by the
National Security Council but there was
liaison at all levels the CIA was
nervous about the role the Senate might
play in this war senator Clark Foreign
Relations Committee made a trip to
Africa to review the situation a fact
our trip to report to the Senate see I
watched him was some apprehension to see
that he didn't get information we didn't
want him to have the Senate led by
senator Clark shut down the angola
program in december of 75 well the
Senate was shutting us down
Cuban army eventually of 10 to 15,000
combat soldiers make 21 aircraft tanks
and just swept over the FNLA and UNITA
and we lost decisive when a Vittorio
a victory it can be our island silly
DoDEA the Africa that will change the
course of African history Nobby
so do than annoy the victory of the
heroic people of Angola nevertheless I
think we could have won the thing if we
had gone in very quickly when I went out
there and came back I recommended that I
said the forces are about equal right
now and if we go in with immediate
abundant support we can win we can take
Luanda by that meant tactical air and
American advisers put in a several
hundred troops very quickly and put in
some of these really monstrous weapons
airplanes you know that fly around
shooting eight thousand rounds a minute
down and you'd have been towanda just
like that it appears from what you said
that you advocated that the United
States should go into Angola with large
weapons lots of firepower a small
detachment of Americans and that your
plan was rejected and that was the final
straw that did it feel no that's very
definitely a misunderstanding yesterday
we got distracted we were into that and
then we didn't get a chance to pursue it
probably changing of cameras or
something I was sick at my stomach that
we were going into Angola
I was I was depressed that the agency
would be letting itself get dragged into
another paramilitary adventure that
quickly after get Nam when it would
obviously not succeed we couldn't
possibly stay with it the Senate oppress
the public wouldn't be about to let us
escalate something up to the level it it
would have a chance of winning and
it would be highly damaging to the
nation and to the CIA particularly to to
let ourselves get dragged into some such
a thing once and at the outset when they
offered me this job then I had a choice
of you know what do i do do I
participate or do I resign or do I
quietly lobby for a some other job and
let someone else run the angola program
and my decision was that i was going to
stay with the program because it was too
interesting to see how does the United
States get dragged into these things and
how does the CIA conduct them once it's
in them I don't think anybody could
could turn down that kind of an
opportunity just to know that it's not
what some newspaperman is telling you
what happens when he doesn't really know
himself
it's what's really happening you were
there running it so I decided to
participate and in order to make sure
that I remained on the inside I remained
a good good soldier throughout the whole
thing I did not walk or fight it until
we got into phases that I thought were
just beyond the pale such as alliances
with the South Africans and mercenaries
for example when I went to Angola was
sent out there to come back with a
military assessment and that's what I
recommended when I got back if you guys
want to win we can do it a dramatic
weapon a horrendous weapon if you will
against the MPLA at that time would have
just brushed on the side it would have
decimated him it would have wiped them
out and the FNLA would have been tawanda
in a few moments
suppose they had taken your military
recommendation how would you felt
I would have stayed as taskforce chief
and participated I if you're going to do
something you know if you're going to
learn French or a foreign language the
least you can do with your poor
pronunciation is speak out and I think
it's there are certain things that are
criminal but you compound it by losing
if you're going to go into Angola if you
have some national compulsion to go into
Angola at least the United States
position would be much stronger if you
won and if they had accepted my
recommendation at that point I would
have been much happier if if they had
gone ahead and won and I was with the
contemptible middle ground that they
followed